[Music]
foreign
ladies and gentlemen here we are well
you know I didn't want to just do hey
you guys or whatever I usually do want
to like change it up would it be
exciting I want to do like a circusy
kind of thing well because I guess
that's kind of like related to this
movie because it's kind of like this is
a good movie I've never seen it you know
what's crazy okay
I didn't realize
um until because I saw this movie a
million times probably uh in the 80s
when it was on cable
and I loved it I still kind of like have
a lot of affection for it I didn't
realize until recently how reviled this
movie is why is this a lot of people and
I don't really get it like a lot of
people really really don't like this
movie and I mean when even when it came
out
like uh you know it made like no money
everyone was like [ __ ] that critics
hated it and even like nowadays like on
Rotten Tomatoes I think it only has like
25 positive reviews and I'm just like
they're nothing wrong with this movie I
don't get it now okay now I will say in
defense of like you know the haters it's
not a horror movie it is kind of like
sold as a horror movie it's not exactly
a horror movie it has horror elements to
it
um and I get that in some aspects maybe
it's a little over ripe it's a little
like all like teetering on Camp but in a
way it's like kind of like that's what I
always liked about it I am unabashedly
it is I was gonna say guilty pleasure
but I'm not guilty about it so you know
what I mean so it's not a guilty
pleasure I just like this movie and you
know what I mean so I didn't even
realize like how
how so many people even a lot of horror
fans like don't really care for it and I
just I was curious to like let you watch
it because you were coming at it with
fresh eyes I've seen it a million times
I hadn't seen it in many years but I saw
it so many times back in the old days
that I was like oh I love this movie and
I had like portions of it memorized but
I wanted you to see it to see like to
get like kind of a critical reassessment
but you liked it though yeah
yeah I don't think I didn't see anything
wrong with it I didn't either it's
definitely kind of like a
like alternate universe this didn't
happen in the Mary Shelley writings it's
it's a different play on it it has a
happy ending and Frank the Frankenstein
creature wins in it
yeah but the way the story was told like
that's how it should have gone
probably I mean you've seen the other
you've seen the other stories where he
[ __ ] kills himself a c on a damn
Iceberg and [ __ ]
why not see it where Frankenstein the
creature [ __ ] actually wins
and gets what he wants and he's a good
guy you know the real monster was
[ __ ] Victor Franks or well they don't
call him Victor in this one but Dr
Charles in this Charles yeah in this one
the monster is actually named me yeah
he's given that name right actually to
make
Dr Frankenstein's the the villain in
this one he's the monster well in the
place I mean you could argue that in the
novel documentary like he's still the
villain
um you know yeah the monster like kills
a bunch of people and you know but he's
more sympathetic than because the thing
about it is that he's torture in the
[ __ ] poor animal right I I kind of
feel like he didn't like ask to be
created and you can understand like why
he does the [ __ ] that he does and even
in the original novel the doctor is the
bad guy I'm not really sure because it's
like well and you know in in the context
of Mary Shelley's time because he was
usurfing power that should only
rightfully belong to God he's creating
life you know or belong to women like
you know he because he's a man he can't
create life he's not he's playing God
essentially yeah and so and also like he
compounds that error by not taking
responsibility for his creation uh and
therefore allowing his creation to like
run rough shot over like every and like
kill people and [ __ ] like that so he's
like didn't take responsibility and that
was another sin so he's the villain in
the original novel too and he's
undoubtedly the villain in this one but
the monster is much more sympathetic he
does kill a dude but the dude had it
coming uh to be fair and um yeah and he
ends up like getting the girl in the end
this is not
I've seen a lot of things saying this is
a remake of James Wales Bride of
Frankenstein from 1935. it's not it's
not a remake of Bride of Frankenstein if
anything it's kind of a sequel
it kind of starts at the like because
the Bride of Frankenstein I feel like
the bride gets created like toward the
end
this starts with the creation of the
bride and then like Carries On from
there so it's not anything I don't want
to say it's nothing to do with Mary
Shelley's novel but
I mean the [ __ ] that happens in it
wasn't in the novel like other than the
creation of the bride and the creature
you know you know Frankenstein creating
the bride for the creature and then her
not liking him and then like the the
tower burning down and [ __ ] like that
but then it just that's happens at the
beginning and then it like goes on a
different direction like he's exploring
some other [ __ ] so it's more like a
sequel than a remake is what I'm saying
so I don't know I don't know why
everybody hates this movie so much but
apparently everybody does I didn't
realize because like I said I saw it
in probably like the late 80s it's it
came out in 1985.
in the theater and uh I think it made
less than four million dollars profit I
don't remember I don't know that you
might I don't know how much it costs to
make but it was not cheap uh you can
tell by looking at it it's a good
looking movie it's a good looking movie
and if they shot it on location like in
France and Italy and it's really really
nice like the cinematography is really
nice so I imagine effects are good it
costs considerably more than four
million dollars and it made less than
four million dollars back at the box
office and got a critical drubbing I
mean Jennifer Beals who's in this as the
bride she got a Razzie nomination I
don't think she won but she got a Razzy
nomination for worst actress now there's
nothing wrong with her performance which
no I like I I wish I do like Jennifer
Beals I wish they had got a British
actress but other than that I don't
really there's nothing wrong with it it
doesn't bother me no there's nothing
wrong with this movie no I actually I
really really like this movie like I
said and it's like I said it's not even
guilty pressure pleasure because I'm not
guilty about it I'm not guilty about it
no there's nothing wrong with this no
so uh in case you guys don't know
because there's really I looked on
YouTube to see if there was some other
reviews of this there are a few but not
many like my my guy like grumpy Andrew
uh that British guy love him by the way
Grump grumpy Andrews horror house that's
the name of his uh Channel I don't know
how many subscribers he has but he
should have more because he's awesome
but
um he did a review of this he did not
care for it
uh and a couple of other guys did but
there's really not a lot of reviews of
this and I just find that very odd I
think a lot of people don't even
remember that this movie exists
but it's just we were scrolling through
the [ __ ] last night and
um we didn't know like we were just I
told Tom to pick a movie and he's like I
can't pick anything whatever and then I
was like okay fine so I started
scrolling with this [ __ ] it was either
on 2B or Amazon Prime or something like
that I was like ooh the bride I was like
have you ever seen that and he's like no
and I was like oh my God I love this
movie and I want to see it again so we
watched that man we ordered some pizzas
yeah and we sat there on the bed like
eating pizzas and watching the bread it
was like it was fun I thought but yeah I
don't know I don't know why everybody
hates this movie so much though Sabrina
said I love it too I remember seeing it
as a kid on TV and loving it yeah and
I'm I'm glad to say that
watching it I saw it a million times
like I said on cable and I loved it and
so I was curious to see it again like
this many years later and see if it's
still held up and I think it largely
does like I said don't go into it
thinking it's gonna be like a horror
movie because it's not really a horror
movie it's kind of more like I'm not
really sure what I'd call it actually
it's kind of like
um it's got romance aspect to it it's
kind of got some horror elements it's
kind of a drama
more than anything I guess I'd call it
like a drama that's horror adjacent with
a romance sort of
I don't know
the director of this uh movie was Frank
Rodham who has done like several things
but I think he's probably best known for
a Quadrophenia which uh actually had
sting that was Sting's first acting rule
if I'm not mistaken and so sting is in
this too and he's great he makes a great
he's oh my God he's such a dick he was
so good at playing roles like that
though did we talk about we reviewed
Brimstone and treacle right great movie
which is a great movie that also had
sting it well one version of it had
sting because they did a couple
different versions like for British TV
and stuff but the 1982 version that had
sting in it was like he was so great he
was just really really good at playing
like a really like a upper Upper Crust
like [ __ ] he's just really good at
playing those kind of roles if you
haven't seen Brimstone Intrigue with
straight State you gotta see it I call
him string
his name is string Tom's been at the bar
today
yeah yeah if you haven't seen Brimstone
and treacle you got to see it man great
[ __ ] flick it's my that movie's
actually better than this one but this
movie isn't yeah I'd agree this movie
isn't bad I liked it
yeah it's like I still like this movie
okay so okay I think what people don't
like about maybe maybe it was the
expectation maybe they were expecting
something more like Bride of
Frankenstein and it's not really like
that like I said it starts out very
horrorary it starts out very much like
the James whale Bride of Frankenstein
where you have like the classic
Universal looking Monster Lab and
staying I'm just gonna call him sting
even though he's Frankenstein but he's
creating the bride like the monsters
already created like he's down in his
little cell or whatever and he's like
waiting on tenter hooks like for for
staying to like you know make him a mate
or whatever because he can't he promised
that he would which like I said that's
from the book
so he makes the woman
and then when it all works out and he
kind of like opens up the bandages I
guess he has kind of like a change of
heart because he's like well this broad
that I made is like far too hot to be
wasted on
on the creature so I'm gonna I'm gonna
keep this [ __ ] for myself well it's not
so much that like it starts out as
Dr Frankenstein's whole thing like after
because there's the whole thing about
like he makes the bride and then the
bride is just like sees the creature and
she's just like oh no thank you and she
like starts screaming and stuff and then
um you know the creature who's played by
Clancy Brown who is like great in this
he like gets really really mad and he
like tears the whole [ __ ] lab up it
all burns down and everything now they
think that the creature dies in the fire
along with several of Frankenstein's lab
assistants who actually do die in fire
but spoiler alert the creature doesn't
really he actually just escapes and like
[ __ ] off
meanwhile sting has decided that because
he created this woman and she turned out
so so good he's like man I'm [ __ ]
awesome like the way I just made this
all like fantastic and everything and
he's decides he's going to
essentially not only because he's like
not only did I make her body like
perfect like she's beautiful and perfect
and everything but I'm also going to
create her mind and his whole thing is
he wants to create a woman I mean this
is you know a long time ago
um a woman that's equal to a man and
like a new kind of woman you know what I
mean so he's like I'm gonna make her
just as smart as a man which is like
kind of funny but he just as smart as a
man like with logic and reason and all
that kind of stuff because you know
women don't have any of those things but
like I said back then they didn't think
they think they did when this is movie
is set
so that's kind of the whole thing is
that he's going to like it's almost like
a My Fair Lady Pygmalion type story
where he's kind of like creating her you
know not he not only physically created
her but he's gonna like create her
personality as well
and so he's doing that
so the movie actually splits into two at
that point so you're following his
adventures in that regard where he's
trying to like uh you know teach her
things and like integrate her into like
upper class English society or whatever
but then you're also following the
creature who escaped unbeknownst to Dr
Frankenstein and the creature I know
this is gonna sound like I made it up
but I really didn't
the creature escapes and he meets a
little person on the road uh he's played
by David Rappaport and I had forgotten
about his part in this and I was just
kind of like oh man seeing him in this
like made me want to watch Time Bandits
again we should do Time Bandits one of
these days too I've never seen it I know
that's another one you haven't seen and
it's like and I love Time Bandits maybe
we can maybe we can do that one on
Tuesday because I think it might be on
HBO max if it's still on there it was
like a few weeks ago
but um but yeah so he's on his way to
Budapest to join the circus and uh
Clancy Brown's creature like kind of
saves him from a bunch of kids that are
like [ __ ] with them like bullies and
stuff
and so they kind of like team up
and then so half of the movie is
following the two of them going to
Budapest and joining the circus and
their whole friendship and everything
like that which is actually like really
cool what I heard I don't know if this
is true or not
but when they were first making the
movie I guess there was supposed to be
like more [ __ ] with Frankenstein and the
bride and all that because they're I
mean they're like half the movie are a
little bit less than less than half the
movie but the stuff with the creature
and the little person
um is like a pretty significant part of
the movie and I think that that was
because the chemistry the like the
friendship that develops between Clancy
Brown's character and David rapperward's
character is so good and like so
heart-wrenching that I think that they
wanted to focus a little bit more on
that
because one of the things and I didn't
really see this but I mean I can kind of
see why you might think this
a lot of reviewers thought that the
chemistry between sting and Jennifer
Beals was not good
and that it was just kind of like flat
or they didn't really seem to have any
chemistry with one another and that's
why maybe the director chose to focus
more on the creature and like joining
the circus and all that I don't know if
that's true but that's what I heard I
don't know I never really thought that
much
because the thing about it in the
context of the story
I don't think that it's necessarily that
important for there to be chemistry like
romantic Chemistry Between
Sting's character in Jennifer beals's
character because the whole point of
that of that you know branch of the
story
is that Dr Frankenstein was supposedly
doing oh I'm gonna be like a big
feminist and I'm gonna like make a woman
that's just as good but then like when
he succeeds and does that and she's just
like yeah [ __ ] you man it's like I'm
just as good as you are and I can't you
know you can't just like I'm not your
beck and call and you didn't create me
and blah blah blah then he gets mad but
I but like I said that tracks that's
exactly what would happen that's exactly
what would happen the whole boy came it
came in and said yeah what did he say
what was this what was this quote
[ __ ] if you make these women free to be
free to despise us yeah that's what
Henry clairval says that yeah and I'm
like exactly yeah and apparently it took
it took sting slash Dr Frankenstein the
whole thing I don't know what he thought
was gonna happen I was like did you
think though he was a dick but he was a
dick but that see that was kind of the
point though it's just like so what did
he think was gonna happen I'm gonna
create I created a woman's body and I'm
gonna create her mind too and make her
an equal to a man she's gonna be just as
smart as me and just as blah blah it'll
be a new kind of woman
um I was like did you really think she
was gonna put up with your [ __ ] then if
you asked me what he was trying to do
first of all the story is told from a
Victorian point of view yeah yeah okay
well just like the book was he's trying
to be a Stern ass Daddy
to this young creature female creature
that he made he's trying to raise it to
his own standards to basically make it a
man yeah all right but but
that's not how it goes no okay [ __ ]
um which he learns to his detriment
right she grew up she grew and [ __ ]
realized that he was a dick
and then she made her own choice and her
own choice was for the monster yeah who
is this one is not as ugly as he is in
the other ones he's a normal looking guy
I mean it's Clancy Brown he just had a
couple scars on his face yeah and he was
compassionate to her
so she chose that now and boy was the
[ __ ] the monster was the hero he
kills Dr Frankenstein yeah he was really
trying to rape her well he yeah yeah he
was trying to rape her he jumped in
[ __ ] saved her so it is nothing like
the Shelley books but the spirit is
similar because because the monster was
a good guy in the book yeah all right
sort of well he murdered several people
but yeah he did but he was doing it at a
Vengeance he was kind of like a child
because he killed Elizabeth right and he
wasn't a human right so it wasn't
necessarily murdered it wasn't his fault
really it was more like Vengeance
against a [ __ ] a hostile race of
creatures that were trying to kill him
because he wasn't really human so it's
not quite the same yeah he was a a new
creation in the book yeah in this one
he's a lot more human and uh he's an
innocent guy
and he's the hero yeah so because that's
the thing that's why I kind of like
because I think that a lot of maybe a
lot of people that didn't like the movie
were like well what was the deal with
the whole half of the movie being about
the creature and the little person you
know in their whole like little journey
he's such a human being but their show
you know he because when he left he was
like really upset and he like [ __ ] up
the lab and everything and then he ran
off and he was just kind of like you
know simple yeah because you know the
doctor hadn't really like bothered to
teach him anything it seemed like or
much of anything but it showed him like
finding his Humanity like he made a
friend and he learned how to love and
all this other kind of stuff and then
yeah right and then he circles back
around to you know and then him and now
one thing that I wish they had done more
with because I had totally forgotten
about this aspect of it because like I
said I haven't seen this for probably
like 20 25 years was they established
that there's actually kind of a psychic
link I guess you would call it between
the creature and the bride because even
when they're far apart They Don't Really
specify like how far I guess one's in
Budapest and the other one where did the
Frankenstein thing take place was it um
inglestadt right so maybe it was there I
don't remember how far apart those two
places are but um but no matter how far
apart they are like if something happens
like there was one scene where the bride
is like kind of like messing around and
she's like spinning around like getting
dizzy and the monster feels that like
many many miles away so they established
in a few scenes that they have a psychic
connection which apparently is I guess
how they like find one another or
whatever but they don't really do much
with that I think that's probably my
only criticism is that they don't do
enough with that I feel like it doesn't
really
I mean they show it a couple times but
it doesn't really like factor into the
plot is what I'm saying maybe I don't
know unless I like missed something I'm
not sure
um Zach said I wish there was a
Frankenstein movie of similar quality to
the Gary Oldman Dracula movie that one
is in my top ten yeah I kind of feel
like the um Mary Shelley's Frank said
the Kenneth Brana one that wanted to be
that but
it didn't quite get there I wish they
had done it more like that one I kind of
wish I mean the cool thing about the
Coppola's Dracula was that it was so
stylized like it had a lot of flaws but
this is the closest you're gonna get to
the
Francis Ford Coppola Dracula with this
movie when it comes to friends yeah this
is I mean it's Frank is it's very I
don't know even want to know if I say
it's very 80s it is kind it is pretty
80s it's a high quality production it
looks great it looks nice and I've heard
that they've done like a Blu-ray of it
now yeah and I was like reading some of
the Blues and they said that the um
transfer looks gorgeous but yeah it's
got I mean Peak sting this was 1985. he
looks fantastic in this beautiful hair
on that [ __ ] he does have a very
handsome man very handsome man I've seen
some reviews call it a mullet it's not a
mullet no it's that's not a more like a
heavy metal haircut yeah yeah he pulls
it off though I don't usually I know I
don't usually like that hair but now
what I heard I think I heard I think
Grumpy Andrew said this or maybe one of
the other reviews
was that
around this time period when they were
first talking about making Interview
with the Vampire into a movie which
obviously they didn't do until the 90s
but when they were throwing that around
I think sting was one of the main people
that Anne Rice was thinking about for
Vampire Lestat and if you see this movie
you will see what she's talking about
because he actually seeing this movie he
would have made a great list at in this
time period in this time period because
he's just so he's so imperious and he's
so douchey but still kind of hot at the
same time and it's just like his look is
very lestaty
so uh so I can see what she was getting
at I think she wanted like Rucker Howard
too but like by the time that you know
they were talking about movie he had
aged out at that point but staying
around this time period would have been
great like not so much point he was
older probably but yeah this had uh
Jennifer Beals who had just been in
Flash Dance the year earlier I think
this maybe was only her second movie
um like I said you had David Rappaport
who was in uh Time Bandits which one of
my favorite movies of the 80s and then
you had uh some other people like you
had Phil Daniels who was in like [ __ ]
tons of British movies he was in
Quadrophenia also and you had Alexi sale
who if anybody like remembers all the
back from the 80s like the young ones
the British TV show The Young Ones Alexi
sale was uh on that all the time so he's
in this as like the evil circus owner
who's like trying to [ __ ] over like
because you know when the creature and
the little person go and like join the
circus or whatever like he's the
[ __ ] that's running it so he's in it
too there's just
I don't know there's just always
something about this movie that really
really appealed to me it's cut it's long
uh I will say that like I had forgotten
that it was like a little it's a little
over two hours and maybe it didn't need
to be but I don't know it didn't really
bother me all that much I did I was
watching another review earlier and the
guy that was reviewing it looked about
my age I mean he didn't like he wasn't
young or anything like that but he just
he had never seen it before but he
thought it was just like boring like a
lot of it was just kind of like
but maybe but like I said maybe he was
expecting it to be a horror movie and
it's not
it's kind of more like a drama so if you
approach it more like a drama then maybe
I don't know I don't know maybe it's
just me maybe it's because I saw it like
a bunch of times in the 80s and it just
kind of has a Nostalgia factor for me
but you liked it too and you didn't see
it back then no I never I never saw it
back there I thought it was a great
movie
so I thought it was a great movie yeah
quality was good I was glad that I still
was like really into it because I
remembered like so much [ __ ] about it
because I saw it so many times back in
the day but
I was like I was kind of like I was
curious to watch it again but then I was
like man what if I watch it and it's
like really really bad it's like and I
remembered it being good but it's not
but I still really really liked it I
really dug it I don't know I don't know
what it is I don't know why everybody
like hates it so much I don't know I
thought it was good yeah it's a little
over ripe yeah it's a little mutt but I
don't know maybe that's what I like
about it maybe that's what I like about
it I'm not right that was good
Zach says also has anyone told Tommy
looks like Walter White yet no I think
you're the first I don't know nothing
about Walter right who the [ __ ] is
Walter Wright from uh Walter White who's
it from uh what do you call it from that
from that uh show [ __ ] man the show
about the [ __ ] meth dealer I don't
know you know what I mean you're not
breaking bad Breaking Bad yeah Breaking
Bad no I haven't seen you actually you
do kind of look like Walter right now
I'm talking to Patrick right now Patrick
and his girlfriend want to come visit
[ __ ] I said no come on down here and
we'll [ __ ] party they're they're kids
they're like in their 20s it'd be fun oh
children yeah you want if you if Pat if
you're one you and your girlfriend don't
want to come down and visit you stay
here [ __ ] then we'll go out to the
clubs
but they're they're a southern couple
you know who they are that's to do with
the [ __ ] dreads and it's great oh
okay okay yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah you watch them all the
time yeah watch them all the time they
watch us all the time they're talking
about the other Frankenstein movie uh I
couldn't deal with uh Robert De Niro's
the monster I actually
part of that what I couldn't deal with
in that movie is that Kenneth Branagh
was obviously that was like Kenneth
brana's ego the movie
I thought Robert De Niro was like
actually the best thing about that and I
actually do like that movie I'm not
shooting on it too much we reviewed it
not too long ago but I like Kenneth
Brana in some things I get it dude like
you're an awesome Shakespearean actor
okay like some of the steps some of the
Shakespearean movies he's done very very
good he's a good actor I'm not saying
that but he's a little up himself as the
British say
and uh I kind of feel like that movie
that was on full [ __ ] display
especially the whole like creation scene
where he's just like I'm just gonna like
run around all oily and shirtless like
the whole like through the whole Lab and
I'm gonna get all like run around on the
[ __ ] floor with like these super
super tight pants on and he's like
getting all wet and stuff and I'm just
like just stop it stop it like why Dr
Frankenstein wouldn't do that like back
then I'm just not having it but it's
like I don't know I liked Robert De Niro
as the monster I think Kenneth Brana was
my was my issue with that he should have
like dialed it back several notches when
it comes to this movie though I can
understand how maybe like Mary Shelley
purists would get pissed off because it
does it does deviate from [ __ ] the
books
but it doesn't deviate from the spirit
of the books too but no it is it it's uh
it's a story that's kind of uh
what do you call it [ __ ]
um
it's outside the normal realm yeah but
it it it is good that's what she was
talking about and the production quality
was high I liked it I thought it was
good I had a good time watching it I did
too yeah here's the thing man just
because it's a movie doesn't mean it's
the [ __ ] definitive end-all to be-all
about that genre
it's an alternate view on Mary Shelley
the Mary Shelley universe and I was like
okay yeah I accepted it
I mean I'm not as stringent on friend on
Frankenstein I'm not a [ __ ]
Frankenstein freak you know where oh
shit's got to be
solid it's got to be perfect compared to
what she wrote
I'm not really like that uh as long as
it's a good movie I'm happy I thought it
was good I just thought it was good yeah
it's a good movie and
it is in the spirit of Shelley
yeah it's it it's not like the books but
it's it was fun but like I said I kind
to feel like they didn't
they didn't really try to fool anybody
in that regard they never said oh this
is an adaptation yeah or this is a
remake of the James whale Bride of
Frankenstein which is also not book
accurate either like to a large degree
it's more like alternate universe yeah
well it's just like they were taking the
characters and like exploring a little
bit farther with that like I said they
were kind of taking what happened at the
end of Bride of Frankenstein the 1935
movie and they're like and then we're
gonna like continue on from that like in
a like you said like an alternate
universe or we're exploring one Avenue
of what could have happened to these
characters after that you know what I
mean and you know and the director was
like oh I wanted to do kind of like more
a feminist take on Bride of Frankenstein
which you know you could see what he was
doing with that
um you know but I think it ended up
actually I like that part of the movie
but I do kind of like this stuff with
the creature and uh Ronaldo the little
person I think that's really like the
heart of the movie because man David
Rappaport is so good in this
um and the friendship between the two of
them is just so good like I said I think
they I think that's why they
concentrated so much on that portion of
the story because the chemistry between
those two actors was so good I would say
it was a feminist take but it's not the
third wave negative man-hating take it's
not what it's not what it was it was
just more the reasonable feminist take
the [ __ ] Dr Frankenstein was a dick
to her yeah you know it was very
reasonable what happened and like I said
in a way yeah it really kind of like it
really tracked for me because I said
that's exactly what would happen if you
had some like arrogant douche that could
create life out of nothing and he's like
I'm gonna create the perfect woman oh
and then I have the idea where I'm Gonna
Make Her equal to a man like I said back
in the Victorian era right and then it's
like without thinking it's like oh if
you do that she's going to be like [ __ ]
[ __ ] off you know what I mean like that
didn't seem to occur to him and I'm like
yeah that's that sounds about right
that's about what would happen Sting's
version of masculinity was really more
[ __ ] being Superior yeah he wanted
her to be equal but not really but not
real no it was a false equality right
all right
um there was no real compassion to it
and no real education to it I mean she
knows nothing and instead of [ __ ]
getting down to her level and educating
her you know I mean from nothing uh he
just [ __ ] looks down on her yeah and
he orders other people to educate her
really more than anything else he
doesn't have anything to do with it
and uh then when he's done with her
because she doesn't obey he decides to
rape her yeah you know what I mean so it
wasn't he really was not even a Creator
in that way he created her mechanically
but not spiritually
he wasn't even helping her really he
wasn't even a good
he wasn't even a good [ __ ] uh what do
you call it sponsor
over
just not a good teacher yeah because he
just wanted her to fit into English
society yeah but he didn't really teach
her anything like I said he didn't teach
her any compassion or anything like that
and I think that's where kind of like
the movie and maybe they didn't get this
across as well as they could have but I
think that's why what that's why the
movie is kind of in two parts that they
kind of like it's not two parts
necessarily but they switch back and
forth between the two stories and then
they kind of come together again at the
end because the monster in his
friendship with Ronaldo
you know in the circus and everything is
learning compassion friendship
everything like that meanwhile the bride
is like she's learning you know to read
and she's learning like all the right
things you're supposed to do all the
right [ __ ] you're supposed to wear all
the [ __ ] you're supposed to say you know
she's she's learning to be that but
she's not like getting anything like
emotional she's not getting any
compassion she's not getting anything
from him because he just wants to make
her it's almost kind of like he wants to
make her he's more worried about like
logic and reason and things like that
and he's not really worried about
because she kind of like
grows up quicker than he anticipated and
she like runs off and starts like you
know maybe like making eyes at like
dudes Carrie Elwes is in this by the way
um from Princess Bride this is he was
very very young in this well I think
Princess Bride was only a year after
this but yeah but so she she starts to
like kind of go off on her own and
resents him resent sting like [ __ ]
busting her balls all the time about
doing this that and the other because he
kind of starts treating her like a child
even after she's clearly yeah I don't
want to say she surpassed him
necessarily but she's clearly like an
equal to him and she's just like what
the [ __ ] you know who who the [ __ ] are
you why can you tell me in this story
sting plays a [ __ ] Victorian [ __ ]
all right
um most dudes in the modern era wouldn't
have actually liked this guy okay I
would hope not no no
and I'm a [ __ ] okay you are kind of
I'm a dick I wouldn't do it
I would not have acted like to do
so he he's more of a he's more of a a
more of an example of how not to be more
in this story it's a morality Tale
okay he's a Creator but only in a
technical sense yeah not in a spiritual
sense and that's what they're talking
about in the movie yeah uh he he
couldn't give the human touch to anybody
because he didn't have it he didn't
really have it he was just a [ __ ]
very right-brained [ __ ] very well
very left brain okay yeah he was more
I'm sorry I'm sorry very left brain very
[ __ ] digital yes or no type
[ __ ] he wasn't a balance no no
no
and uh so that's what the story is about
so you know if you're a dude don't get
assaulted about it because you're
probably not like this [ __ ]
either I would hope not because you are
please get help yeah I think I do is try
to read it all there and insult men now
they're just insulting that [ __ ]
and [ __ ] Ultra Macho [ __ ] Trend
out [ __ ] like myself I wouldn't
act like that either I'd be like baby I
love you you're [ __ ] beautiful no no
no no no no you know you can eat eat
like this okay I'll show you how to use
tearing [ __ ] apart or this is okay baby
you know I would have just let it have
anything I'm like you do you baby yeah
he didn't have any compassion he was
uptight up his own ass he was up his own
ass well there was a scene earlier where
yeah he was like trying to teach her
like the words for things and well he's
punishing her hard he doesn't tell her
for a long time that he's like oh by the
way I stitched you together of corpses
which I understand that's a lot he's
like basically it's like oh well we
found you like you have amnesia right
and like somebody found you and like you
know we put out all these inquiries like
looking for your family but nobody came
forward so I guess nobody cares about
you so I took you in blah blah blah and
so I have to like teach you how to like
talk again and do all this other [ __ ] so
there's a scene where
he's like they're sitting at the dinner
table and he won't let her eat until she
correctly identifies like chicken you
know what I mean like and she's clearly
struggling but he's just like very like
you know he's just like sitting there
like not letting her have any it's like
like I said he's very authoritarian he's
very I don't know he's just like a real
jerk about it he just up his own ass
Taiwan dick yeah yeah and you could I
mean yeah he's very very
um you can tell he's very very arrogant
and he's like really really
condescending like everything
about it even though he makes all these
noises about you know I want to make her
equal to a man it is illegal to me he
doesn't mean it he still feels Superior
to to hit to her even when she clearly
like I said surpasses him or you know
matches him in intelligence and even a
couple times like calls him out on some
[ __ ] he got wrong yeah
um you know he gets like really really
butt hurt about it which like I said
that also tracks but yeah so I I was
gonna talk
okay Frankenstein all this [ __ ] we're
gonna have equality like a [ __ ]
between men and women would have this
equality and [ __ ] it he he's
bullshitting it's not it's not true
equality he's virtue signaling okay he's
just saying that he doesn't actually
want equality with with these women well
yeah because when it happens not like
that yeah
they're equal to us and that means that
they have the right to despise us and
like yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's how
that's gonna work y'all [ __ ] sucks
it's like maybe if you stop sucking they
wouldn't hate you so much right but yeah
that
that's what they're talking about yeah
all right and it's like I had like I
said I remembered a lot of that kind of
subtext and stuff like that but I don't
know I really liked that well the thing
about it you what you were saying
earlier about like dudes get offended
about that kind of stuff I I always feel
like if dudes get offended by this and
this this movie came out a long time ago
if you get if you get offended yeah then
that then that must mean that you think
that it's talking about you yeah you
know what I mean yeah if you don't if
you don't think it's talking about you
then you wouldn't get it I did that's
all I gotta say I'm a hyper masculine
[ __ ] I was I wasn't offended
because I understood it I was like yeah
those are dead
right and like I said if you get
offended because like because they're
like [ __ ] on sting or whatever I'm
like then you might be like staying and
sting is clearly the villain clearly the
villain he's clearly gotta stick up his
ass yeah yeah he plays a great villain
though I got to say I mean we're saying
that but sting is like really good
[Laughter]
it's below [ __ ] uh the dude from
YouTube what was that motherfucker's
name uh Bono Bono yeah Bono was even
more of a dick but um I still liked Alex
still like steak he's a dick okay
and he was a very feat is what they're
talking about yeah I always had that
feeling from him
but I'm not going to attack his work
everything that he did I thought was
frecka very good
I really liked him in this he makes a
great job Frankenstein Dune Brimstone
treacle [ __ ] he's great and perfect
this movie he's very good which is
another role like this where he well he
plays a literal demon yeah in Brimstone
and treacle and he kills it yeah he
kills it yeah he's good because that's
kind of his that's his wheelhouse man
yeah is playing like these kind of like
Upper Crust
douchebags yeah like really really
arrogant yeah condescending [ __ ]
he's very very good at that and sting
personally as a dude was a very talented
good-looking dude I love the police yeah
yeah very good [ __ ] oh his his music
his vocal work is [ __ ] masterpiece
that's why he's a dick he knows it
that's why he's trying to put your
girlfriend on his dick he's an alerted
his lowest position that's what I mean
we can be mad about it oh man how good
he was he but he's real good well see
that's the thing you can get away with
it more if you're like talented if
you're like not talented and you're a
douche then everyone's like shut up yeah
but they'll let you get away with like
an alarming amount of dickery if you're
like actually good at [ __ ] and I will
admit you know I don't know sting
personally maybe he's a lovely man but
he always kind of came across he's not
as douchey as Bono but he always kind of
came across as like slightly lesser
douchey than that maybe just
sanctimonious more than yeah yeah yeah
sanctimonious but um he's a very
elevated man right which there's nothing
wrong with that I mean you know what I
mean but you know you don't got to be
like all you had some [ __ ] Talent
though the dude was good that's what I'm
saying I still love I mean synchronicity
was the first it was the first album
that I bought on vinyl kids because I'm
old uh with my own money like I had
albums before that other people had
brought had bought for me
yeah synchronicity was the first one
that I actually wanted went to the store
and bought with my birthday money I
loved that album so much I played it
over and over and over and over and over
in 1983. every album and it's still good
I bought it again recently every album
that that dick was on man [ __ ]
[ __ ] ghost in the machine
or whatever that [ __ ] was called oh yeah
every [ __ ] album that guy's on is
[ __ ] great
every album yeah I even like some of his
solo [ __ ] I had like Joe yeah the blue
turtles yeah he's good he's real I had
that on vinyl also he's [ __ ] awesome
I don't think I have it anymore what'd I
do with it I sold a bunch of my records
when I was like starving yeah
nobody's denying that motherfucker's a
God right okay yeah yeah he's [ __ ]
[ __ ] fantastic okay which like I said
gives him some leeway yeah if you're
talented you have like maybe 20 25 more
leeway to act like a douche
maybe 50 he may not be a douche though
I'm sorry
it might be it just always struck me as
a [ __ ] that's trying to throw
your wife on his dick in and why he's
doing a Lotus [ __ ] position and he's
gonna smirk at you why he's fine
although here's the thing too
I kind of feel like the British yeah
um they have a very specific sense of
humor and a lot of it is like kind of
satirical and black and dry so it's like
sometimes in interviews they might just
be taking the piss yeah so they might be
saying [ __ ] like that just to be funny
and they because they think it's
hilarious that other people take it
seriously so it could be because I have
run it and I think Americans don't maybe
less or so nowadays but I kind of feel
like back in the old days like a lot of
times like British and Australians do
this too but they would do like
especially rock stars and stuff and they
would do like interviews and they would
just say like outlandish [ __ ] but they
would say it like with a super straight
face and so it would totally get taken
seriously and everybody will like freak
out and it's like they were just back
there going hey
dumbasses
this [ __ ] series Danny Rowling said
Jenny who's that a picture of uh above
the skull on the table behind you it
looks like Tom savini to me it is
one of uh somebody like sent that to me
it's actually good sign too isn't it I
think so yeah it's a sign Tom safini
yeah
I've met Tom savini a couple times he's
it's funny because we saw him at the
[ __ ] combo he's at every single
Horicon yeah he's a nice dude I met him
a couple times but um I was like a big
fan of his like from the 80s because I
saw like some documentaries back in the
old days of like all his special effects
work he always seems like such a nice
man you know what I mean he and he's
really really into horror and I love
that and he and um his if you guys
didn't know like he was in Vietnam and
he was a photographer in Vietnam so he
saw like actual people like blown up and
like with their guts hanging out and
everything like that and that's kind of
like what inspired when that's [ __ ] up
but that's like what inspired a lot of
his special effects were because he had
seen the real [ __ ] you know what I mean
and he had a thing where he's like I
have to make it look as real as possible
so there's that but yeah it is Tom
savini it's weird because Tom savini
kind of looks like my dad
my dad or my dad kind of looks like yeah
I don't think you I don't think you've
ever met my never mentioned it I mean
obviously my dad's older he doesn't look
like that anymore because he's older now
but and I haven't seen him in several
years but he does kind of look like my
dad when he was younger so I don't think
my dad has a mustache anymore though I
think he shaved it off a long time ago
um Zach said I'm gonna create a new kind
of woman and that boys and girls is how
the 1920s was born yeah because you got
[ __ ] uh well even yeah you got
[ __ ] Metropolis where dude tries to
create a robot woman
and she makes a damn Revolution
happen there's a lot of [ __ ] creating
I kind of feel like there's a lot of
movies like that around this time period
where a dude was like I'm gonna make a
woman and it'll be like the best woman
ever and then she wakes up and she's
like [ __ ] this [ __ ] yeah you suck and
then he's like oh I could not have
foreseen this happening and I was like
it's absolutely you should have foreseen
that happening
I don't know but it's a I just thought
that was like really funny that that was
kind of like the whole
point of this movie really yeah what's
that I'm gonna make a woman that's equal
to a man and he's like oh not like that
and I was like yeah that's exactly how
it happened that's exactly how it
happened he's like no I I meant for you
to be equal in the sense that you still
did everything that I said
you know what I mean I don't know I
thought that was very funny
um all right
does my fair lady count among those
kinds of movies the well I kind of
compare it counts no matter what kind of
movie you talk I kind of it's a great
movie it is I kind of like compared this
a little bit this does have like a my
fair lady kind of thing to it maybe we
should review that one of these days I
know it's not horror it's not you know
anything like that but I don't know I
feel I still feel like that's a classic
that we should probably talk about but
it does have that aspect to it actually
I think in this movie they even
referenced they didn't reference My Fair
Lady obviously but um I think they did
reference uh Pygmalion which my fair
lady is kind of like Loosely based on in
case you didn't know my fair lady was a
great flick yeah I know I like that
movie I like that movie a lot yeah I
like the movie a lot good songs in it
and everything yeah
um but yeah so are we ready to like yeah
we can wrap it up today I think yeah
because we'll uh make us something to
eat you ready yeah I'm sorry all right
oh before we do anything okay so
tomorrow's Monday which means it's a
haunting Mondays so does anybody have
any recommendations
requests for any episodes of a haunting
that we haven't done yet that you want
us to do because if you don't think of
anything if you don't come up with
anything in the next couple minutes
I don't know okay I thought you had one
picked out already no okay I don't I
just said that we'll pick one at random
if nobody has any uh particular requests
because I feel like we've done
we've done the major ones we've done the
ones that everybody requested I think
because I like had a little bit of a
list that people ones that people
requested
and we've done all those I think we
ought to do the one with [ __ ] old
Billy Bean
I've got one where we did a whole show
about that though did we yeah okay a
long time ago
Danny Rowling said the episode where the
house was going to blow itself up was a
good episode uh which one was that do
you remember which one that was yeah the
house gonna blow itself up the house
gonna blow itself that sounds like the
Warrens were involved with that that
house could explode okay that's like
something that's like some Elizabeth
Warren would say Elizabeth Warren is
that her name Elizabeth Warren no what
was your name Lorraine Lorraine Warren
Lorraine Warren Lorraine Warren yeah
yeah
the rain Warren would say some [ __ ] like
that the house will blow up Zach said I
remember an episode about a guy who grew
and grew up in a house with a demon in
the basement well or something
yeah that that might have been the Billy
Bean one or that might have been the um
it wasn't Billy Bee the one with uh uh
the Arnie Cheyenne Johnson one like and
we did a show about that no because that
was all like a whole trial and [ __ ] the
one with the [ __ ] basement that had a
well was uh the one that was a nightclub
where there were heads that supposedly
heads at the bottom of the well it was
uh
[ __ ]
um
it was the one that had all the [ __ ]
Bobby Mackies uh we did it okay Bobby so
we already did that we did a [ __ ] we did
a whole episode like a regular episode
Bobby Mackey's had the one with the
[ __ ] well because some haunting
episodes we did like a whole episode
yeah like before we started doing haunts
so I mean we could always redo the [ __ ]
that was a long [ __ ] time ago we
could but and people there's so many
episodes we haven't done now yeah I kind
of feel like that I don't really
necessarily want to repeat them all
right but
so there's no suggestions
um Danny rolly said I'm looking it up
now okay something in the basement was
going to blow the house I mean I could
probably find it it would just like be
easier if somebody like knew which one
that was I had this one here because the
one that we did last week was Wichi for
her
but I think we already did I know we did
what's on here the dark side we did a
show about that a long time ago which
one was that
I don't even remember but we did a show
about a long time ago because I wrote it
down yeah see see we have we have the
actual CDs to these
for at least the seasons one through
seven uh we got more than that I think
we got them up to about ten don't we
well we have one through seven on DVD
yeah and then I think we bought season
eight and we maybe bought season 11.
okay because there were a couple that
weren't available the digital seasons
are short and they're not that good the
ones that you can buy on
on uh Amazon that's a that series really
went downhill it's it yeah well
everybody kind of agrees so far so far
you know I mean many Rowling said A
Haunting in Connecticut you never did
yet yeah I checked we didn't do a
hunting in Connecticut which one was
that that was one of the pilots we did
it we did a haunting in Georgia let's do
Connecticut then Connecticut was I mean
we might have to buy that separate
because it's not part of the yeah but
it's probably only a couple of bucks
Connecticut is the one that uh had uh oh
[ __ ] wasn't that the one that the um
that The Conjuring Universe movie was I
think so the one that the one that was
taking place in the in the [ __ ] field
the parent family or whatever in the
funeral home right
um was it what's the name of it again
Haunting in Connecticut yeah hunting in
Connecticut was happening in the funeral
home that was
um
I'm thinking I'm thinking of two
different things those are two different
things Connecticut was a funeral home I
think
I don't think it was I think that was
well I don't know I have to go check I
have to check I don't remember okay we
can look it up all right but that's the
okay so that's the one we're gonna do
unless
something intervenes and like we have
some kind of problem or whatever and
then the snedekers yeah no because
Haunting in Connecticut they made it
into a Hollywood movie yeah that's not
the snedeker it's the parent family
p-e-r-r-o-n yeah that's what that was I
don't remember which with that one but
they did two pilots of a haunting uh and
one was a haunting in Georgia the one
with like Mr Gordy and all that we did
that I know we did that show like that
was a long time ago I thought we'd done
a haunting in Connecticut like the other
pilot but I guess we didn't and then
when I looked the other day I'm like oh
yeah I guess we didn't so maybe we
should do that
yeah the snedekers claim they got anal
raped yeah they did yeah and I don't
think they have a rates running down the
road running down the street and the
invisible ghosts were [ __ ] getting up
in that booty while you're running down
the street you're running
and I remember seeing that I remember
hearing that [ __ ] when I was a kid I
think it was on [ __ ] Geraldo or
something one of those daytime talk
shows and when she said that my [ __ ]
hair stood up on the back of my head I
was like what
[Laughter]
raped you went up in your booty and then
she's just like while you were running
why you were running wow that's one
Dexter saw the hand underneath [ __ ]
that girl's nightgown going up like that
grabbing on her titties
and I was just like oh man that's some
sexy [ __ ]
is that really really
[Laughter]
Tom was picturing it here's the thing
wait that wasn't the pig creature rape
was it no that was a different case
here's the thing you know what I mean I
[ __ ] had a poltergeist experience
[ __ ] it was [ __ ] pretty intense me
and my family at Mammoth Mountain she
wrote a book about it
so I had a tendency to believe what
other people said a lot
and I remember the syntheticare case as
having elements of things that I I
believed in
they're like yeah that that may be
possible it is a good episode I mean I'm
not sure if I buy it because that woman
is yeah I'm like well that's not that's
not exactly the kind of [ __ ] that I saw
it's a little bit stronger but maybe
they're stronger than the ones that I
saw you know
um so I didn't know what to believe I
thought the snedekers would tell the
truth listening to it now I don't think
they really were they were in Paranormal
Witness too yeah they did a haunting and
a parallel and they're good with they're
uh good episodes with the snap yeah but
I don't think there's anything to it I
think it
I don't know it's hard to say I don't
know we'll check if there was something
to it it's it
it's not what they're saying
they they've exaggerated
that's I think it's hard to say
I'm skeptical now
I'm skeptical of everybody yeah of
everybody's story is in that regard okay
especially when you get to a point where
you're like hey I was running down the
street being anal raped by
like I keep wanting to say it in public
I keep wanting to say a pig creature but
the anal rape by a pig creature that was
another case yeah which case was that I
don't know those [ __ ] were on
Geraldo or Sally Jess or one of those
like daytime talk shows like back in the
80s or 90s and they talked about yeah
they got raped too but yeah but by Pig
creatures back in the 80s if this [ __ ]
was on TV it probably happened as far as
you
they're like oh [ __ ] well they wouldn't
even go on to they can't say that stuff
on TV if it didn't really yeah it didn't
really happen it's on TV so that should
happen
yeah yeah and I was watching more and
more [ __ ] Jerry Springer and [ __ ]
[ __ ] I'm going oh yeah that [ __ ]
happened even though all those people
were actors yeah and then I ran into
Jerry Springer the [ __ ] French
Quarter down in [ __ ] Javier and
Javier was his name um
down at the [ __ ] um
down at the convent I'm trying to
remember the [ __ ] owner of the
comments what his name was and [ __ ]
Jerry Springer was cool as [ __ ] he would
come to the French Quarter in New
Orleans all the time
he just knew how to like make some money
yeah that was like probably the Persona
that he loved goth girls and he loved
the fetish thing he was he was a nice
guy and uh then later on [ __ ] Marilyn
Manson and [ __ ] uh Trent Reznor
started to show up at [ __ ] the club
and it was a private club that in those
days over Javier's place it's called the
convent it was in every place did I say
Javier again yeah his name Pierre what's
his name Pierre Pierre's place I mean
you know it's gone now long time ago it
was across the street from the crystal
the dark uh if you got that's probably
gone too now
but uh
yeah 90s and early 2000s it was [ __ ]
wild time
Samantha is talking about the entity
that case was um that was uh California
right yeah California and what was that
[ __ ] investigator's name
I've talked to him before and I don't
know if there's much to that guy yeah we
did a show about that a long time ago
like the case behind that yeah
um he was a parapsychologist yeah I'm
not sure he's real honest
that's the thing it's like some of the
[ __ ] that happened because she had like
some spiritual rape happened too yeah
but she also had like a lot of mental
issues there was a lot of other it's a
fascinating case I'm not saying that but
she did have a lot of other issues it
could have happened it could have sure I
just we weren't there Doris bither thank
you Doris bither that's right we weren't
there so we can't really see all I could
think of was Barbara Hershey but that
was the actress that played her in the
movie yeah but yeah Doris bither was her
real name but uh yeah all right so we'll
try we'll do The Haunting in Connecticut
thing because you know that's if we can
uh find it someplace like I said if not
then I'll announce the other then we'll
pick something else and I'll announce it
tomorrow I'll announce it tomorrow
anyway uh just so everybody knows so if
you want to watch it ahead of time so we
will see you guys again tomorrow evening
at 6 p.m EST for our haunting Mondays
and we'll uh see you again then hope you
guys enjoyed the movie review today good
night